Now, this plot might have been a little bit tricky,
so let's walk through it together. I'll assign age to the
X parameter, and then I'll assign females divided by males, to
the Y parameter. This will give me my ratio. And then
I just need to make sure that I pass my
newest data frame to data. We'll add a geome line to
connect the points, and then we'll also add a horizontal line.
This geom_hline will take a couple parameters. We'll set the y-intercept
to one, the alpha equal to 0.3, and the
line type equal to two. Running this code, we get
out ratio plot. We can easily see that for very
young users, the median female user has over two and
a half times as many friends as the median male
user Clearly it was helpful to condition on age, and
understanding the relationship of gender with friend count. This helped
assure us this pattern is robust for users of many
different ages. And it also highlighted where this
difference is most striking. Now, there are many
processes that can produce this difference, including the
biased distribution from which this pseudo Facebook data
was generated. One idea which shows the complexity
of interpretation here, is that people from particular
countries who more recently joined Facebook are more
likely to be male with lower friend counts.